democrats already in the throes of their
worst week since 1865 now suffer a
further
indignity a federal court has just
invalidated obamacare in its entirety
russia collusion is a hoax michael
avenatti is headed to prison
and now the last vestige of barack
obama's legacy is headed for the dustbin
of history
coincidentally the new york times
insists this week
that an all-good all-knowing
all-powerful god
is logically impossible they make a bad
argument but after a week like this
who could blame the new york times
writers for losing their faith
all of that and more i'm michael knowles
and this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
this was basically the new york times's
reaction
to finding out that there was no russian
collusion donald trump is fully
exonerated
the headline basically might as well
have said god does not exist
fair enough i understand we will examine
a very bad
opinion piece in the times by peter
atterton
we'll get to that later first we just
need to do a little bit of a roundup
because i think we're losing some of the
good stuff in the craziness of the news
cycle
we found out we found out yesterday the
day before
robert mueller files his report and it
totally exonerates donald trump
mueller himself totally exonerates
donald trump on russian collusion
and then the attorney general barr and
deputy attorney general rod rosenstein
exonerate trump totally on the question
of obstruction
then at that very same moment michael
avenatti
the democrat celebrity lawyer trump
antagonist is arrested
for extortion not 24 hours later
that all happened then i was on the air
doing ben's radio show yesterday as i'm
on the air
there is breaking news apparently
unrelated although there are no
coincidences these days
that the world's fastest melting glacier
which is in ice or in greenland rather
is now
growing in size it is now gaining ice
so as all of this is happening as every
aspect
of the democrat narrative over the last
two years is cracking and falling apart
at the very same time global warming
falls apart too
the example the main ice glacier example
that they're pointing to
as evidence of global warming starts
growing ice
all over again because all nature is but
art unknown to thee
and then then on top of all of that a
little story comes out
the doj is officially agreeing with a
federal court decision in december
that invalidates all of obamacare
this this story is particularly
interesting you'll probably remember
the supreme court famously upheld
obamacare on some dubious reasoning
now the federal government the the
federal court
and the department of justice are
agreeing that obamacare is invalid this
is going to go to an appeals court
and we'll see where it goes from there
and then and then finally
maybe the best news of the week i'm
going to have to check to see if we get
any updates on this
mitch mcconnell cocaine mitch himself
is ordering a vote in the senate on the
green
new deal oh oh how good this is
how could anyone doubt the existence of
god
let's get to obamacare first
and before we get to obamacare first
let's make a little money honey with
expressvpn
you know how is that for a tease oh you
just want to hear two but you got to
wait for one second this is important
especially these days especially with
lots of hacking lots of
questionable info things going on with
the russians and the federal government
you think that cyber crime is something
that happens to other people you may
think that no one wants your data
oh hackers couldn't grab your password
your password is password one with a
capital p and an exclamation point no
one's gonna guess that right stealing
data from unsuspecting people on public
wi-fi
is one of the simplest and cheapest ways
for hackers to make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted
you may as well be writing your
passwords and credit card numbers on a
huge billboard
for the rest of the world to see which
is why i decided to take action
to protect myself from cyber criminals i
have express
vpn expressvpn secures and anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data and hiding your public ip
address
it has easy to use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone and tablet
turning on expressvpn takes only one
click
expressvpn allows you to surf on public
wi-fi without being snooped or having
personal data stolen
and it's less than ten so sorry less
than seven bucks a month
to get the same express vpn protection
that i've got
it's rated number one vpn service by
techradar has a 30-day money-back
guarantee protect your online activity
today find out how you get three months
free
at expressvpn.com michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael for three months free with a
one-year package expressvpn.com
michael mich ael to learn more
how has obamacare been invalidated
the news today is the filing of the
department of justice to side
with a federal court judge reid o'connor
who
in december invalidated obamacare
so now this was a district court that
means that this issue is going to go up
to the appellate court
you say we've i thought we've already
adjudicated obamacare i thought
obamacare was already upheld
yes except now circumstances have
changed
now this decision is going to go up to
an appellate court and it's going up to
a very conservative appellate court so
it's going up to the
the fifth circuit which means very
likely this is heading for the supreme
court
again what is the argument here the
argument
when obamacare was upheld thanks to that
traitor john roberts
is that the individual mandate
you know that you have to pay the
penalty when you don't have health
insurance under obamacare
the individual mandate was
appropriate to congress's powers of
taxation
that was the argument to uphold
obamacare
now it was even a little more clever
than that it said well the the obamacare
mandate is a penalty for the purposes of
hearing
this case but it's a tax for the
purposes of adjudicating this case and
because it's a tax
it's valid it's constitutional and it
will be upheld
okay the argument was always too clever
by half it was a weak argument
however what has changed what's changed
is that the individual mandate has been
repealed so we've been a little upset
with president trump
because he didn't repeal obamacare right
he said you said you were going to
repeal obamacare you had two years to do
it you didn't do it
well whose fault was that senators like
john mccain
who said they would vote to repeal
obamacare then ultimately voted not to
repeal obamacare
very frustrating however
you'll also remember in 2017 we got that
tax cut we got the tax reform law from
the trump administration
and what was hidden in that tax law was
the repeal of the individual mandate
now this seems appropriate because the
reason that obamacare was upheld in the
first place is they said that the
mandate was a tax
it wasn't really a tax it was a penalty
but by saying it was a tax then in the
tax reform law
they get rid of the individual mandate
okay what does that do
it removes the taxing mechanism of
obamacare
so it removes the justification for
upholding obamacare as constitutional
under congress's powers to tax if
obamacare
no longer includes a tax then the chief
justification for upholding obamacare
goes away now the individual mandate is
essential to the law
it's inseparable the mandate is the
mechanism of the law you have to make
sure that everybody buys insurance
or the law falls apart so now what is
going to happen now the the argument
for obamacare is under the interstate
commerce clause or something like that
the the argument to uphold obamacare is
no longer taxation they'll say well
it's regulating interstate commerce but
first of all it would have to be
regulating interstate commerce that the
government mandates which is
highly dubious but but does that
argument
hold up once you get rid of the taxation
no so the doj has now
pounced to use the language of the
mainstream media they see an opening
here they see that this is headed for a
conservative leaning appellate court and
they're going in with a brand new
argument and you could see
down the line we're not going to see it
anytime soon
the overturning of obamacare the
adjudication that obamacare is
unconstitutional
and it's only tuesday we got the mueller
report on friday
we got news that there were no new
indictments which means the russian
investigation was just done
on friday then on sunday we got the
letter from a.g barr
saying that trump was exonerated on
everything
then on monday we got news that michael
avenatti got arrested and then on
tuesday we get news that obamacare might
finally be declared unconstitutional
years after it was
wrongly declared constitutional
how can this week get any better
how can it possibly get any better now
we are still having fun i told you
yesterday i said we should have fun we
should celebrate
then we should be furious we're still
having fun
look the prospect of losing obamacare in
its entirety is really really great
but we do have a reckoning coming
there is a reckoning we should start
moving toward
the reckoning the reckoning
is in two parts just like the russian
interference was in two parts
just like the scandal of the russian
collusion hoax investigation
had two parts the reckoning has two
parts too the media
and the politics
some people in the conservative
wing say that we need to just move on
just move on no more investigations
we've had enough come on it's no
don't be a bigger man be a better person
just take the higher road there is
nothing
moral about just moving on
there is nothing on the high road
about just moving on this is not water
under the bridge it would be
very wrong to just move on because they
haven't
apologized and they are just going to do
it
again all these people who lied through
their teeth
people who were entrusted with the
federal government people who had the
public trust
people who had the public trust as
members of the media lied they didn't
just get it wrong they lied through
their teeth
and they are totally unapologetic about
it and they will do it again
here is what we've seen for the last two
years breaking news
a bombshell today is a turning point
today was historically bad for president
trump today
was a turning point a turning point
we're at a turning point here
the beginning of the end for the trump
presidency we have another bombshell
mike pence might have to assume the
office of the presidency
rumblings of the word impeachment
breaking news another bombshell
out of the white house i believe this is
the beginning of the end i do too it's
really the beginning of the end he may
be feeling the walls closing in on him
all the walls closing in on him
the walls closing in on him breaking
news a new bombshell one astrologer
says this means the beginning of the end
for president donald trump trump will
resign
trump is going to resign is this the
tipping point i know we've said it
over and over so we've heard that for
two years
do we think that we're going to get
apologies for this now do we think that
we're going to get them admitting
that they were totally wrong do we think
that we're going to get some
self reflection from them no absolutely
not what we're getting is a doubling
down we'll get to that in a second but
first
let's make a little money honey with the
way i heard it with mike rowe
if you're looking for more great
podcasts to listen to but you're short
on time
you have got to check out the way i
heard it with mike rowe this podcast
gives a unique take on american history
each episode is just 10 minutes or less
the way i heard it is for the curious
mind with a short attention span every
episode is a short mystery
about a famous person or event you know
filled with surprising facts you don't
know
from pop culture to politics from actors
to athletes from history to hollywood
the story is never what you think and
the big reveal at the end is always
surprising it's america's number one
short form podcast it's been downloaded
more than 87 million times
if you haven't checked it out start with
episode 100
how not to ruin your most expensive
suit this podcast i was just listening
to it
it's i think it's about eight minutes
long and it's about
feeling a little public pressure it's
about a little bit of the intersection
between reality and show business
it's about one of the most pivotal
moments in all of history
and it's about how not to urinate on
yourself you're going to love it it's a
good episode
uh micro is just terrific it's a
reagan-esque podcast i just really like
it
mikerow.com podcast today listen and
subscribe to the way i heard it
m-i-k-e-r-o-w-e dot com
slash podcast again mikerow.com podcast
collusion collusion collusion i sound
like maxine waters
walls are closing in the noose is
tightening donald trump's going to jail
don jr is going to jail
jared kushner is going to jail it's all
happening it's all
russian collusion collusion collusion
collusion
it's not just that we are mocking them
for their
bad reporting it's that we are fighting
a battle of the truth against pure
propaganda and the propaganda has a lot
of institutional support
because for all of this bunk garbage
totally fictitious reporting it's not
just that these guys were on your
airwaves and printing your newspapers
they won awards for it the new york
times and the washington post
won a pulitzer prize for publishing lies
here is the for their russian collusion
reporting
the new york times and the washington
post won pulitzer prizes the highest
prize in journalism
for quote deeply sourced relentlessly
reported coverage in the public interest
that dramatically furthered the nation's
understanding of russian interference
in the 2016 presidential election and
its connections to the trump campaign
the president-elect's transition team
and his eventual administration
well i i can give you all the
understanding you need of russian
interference as it relates to the trump
campaign
there i did it that was it did you catch
it i'll do it again ready
that's it i'm gonna that's gonna be my
next book all
of the evidence of the russian
interference and collusion
with the trump campaign that
won them a pulitzer prize and this is
why it's so important
to go after these guys with everything
we've got to bring more investigations
to bring them before judges
and to put them into orange jumpsuits
because it's not just a bunch of idiots
on cnn
it's not just jim acosta it's not just
ron burgundy on cnn
it is it's a conspiracy
i don't know how else to put it is it a
conspiracy when it's true
we know that the federal government
and the democrats and the media
conspired together to push
a lie we know that for a fact
who exactly committed what improprieties
is the next question that's what we'll
find out
with investigations we know that for a
fact with such institutional support
all of the print media all of the
mainstream media the pulitzer prizes
all of the accolades of this popular
culture
all the way down to our pillars of
government the doj the fbi
all the way down to the longest
continually extant political party
the democrat party all the way down to
the barack obama administration
spying on his political opponents trying
to prevent the republicans from winning
the next election
all of these institutions working
together
to subvert the rule of law and to lie
and to push
lies through their teeth it would be
so wrong to just let this go as water
under the bridge the washington post
bragged when they won that pulitzer
prize that its reporting quote
helped set the stage for the special
counsel's ongoing investigation of the
administration
they're bragging that they set up a hoax
sham investigation
now they're unapologetic and you know
the cnn president jeff zucker came out
did he say whoops we got it wrong
we got it dead wrong we got it wrong for
two years
maya culpa maya culpa man maxima culpa
no this is what he said he said quote
we are not investigators we are
journalists and our role
is to report the facts as we know them
which is exactly what we did
that sounds like a line from dr
strangelove that sounds like
the punchline of an snl sketch we're not
investigators
we're journalists there's no fighting
here this is the war room
that's what he's saying there's no
investigating here this is a newsroom
what what an amazing statement i don't
think jeff zucker is an idiot so i think
he's just trolling us at this point
we are not investigators we are
journalists and our role is to report
the facts
as we know them how do you know the
facts
the way you know the facts is that the
democrat party sends you talking points
and you spout them shamelessly the way
you're supposed to know facts
is to investigate journalism requires
investigation
reporting requires investigation i
suppose broadly speaking
an opinion writer is a journalist a
commentator is a journalist they have to
do some investigating they have to do a
little research
they have to follow they have to have
coherent arguments
based on sound premises and evidence you
have none of that and you're proud of it
you're joking about that
you say no no we're investigators
we just we have the facts but you don't
need to investigate the facts it's like
aoc
listen it doesn't matter if you're
factually correct as long as you're
morally right that's what we're saying
that's what that's what cnn is saying
wholly unapologetic now they are denying
their jobs as journalists this is what
we were talking about yesterday
all the various responses to this this
is the example of gaslighting
so we did a good job we did our job oh
you thought um okay i see you thought
that because we're
news reporters that we're supposed to
investigate the news
no no i i get it i'm so i was a
misunderstanding
no we we just say whatever we want to
say we say our truth i mean that's
basically what he's saying he's saying
our role is to report the facts as we
know them
but you have to know them first and you
can't know them if you don't investigate
what he's really saying is our role is
to report
our truth you can't you don't know
our truth who are you to say what our
truth is we're cnn
bananas apples remember that stupid
commercial they use this is an apple
this is a banana we're real news we're
bananas here at cnn
in in this statement he's saying no no
it doesn't matter it's just our truth
our truth is what bananas we love
bananas
bunch of bananas over at cnn wholly
unapologetic now they're denying it so i
i found this this came from the new york
post yesterday i hope that you've got
your brackets
this is mueller madness there's mueller
madness right there in the center
there's bob mueller's head
you see and then you've got all the
brackets okay so we've got
the cable news bracket we've got the
network news
bracket we've got the uh the print news
over here we've got the twitterratty
over here
and so then they go head-to-head you've
got rachel maddow and anna navarro
okay you've got john oliver and donnie
deutsch morning joe versus john brennan
we'll get to john brennan in the second
former cia director
now he's basically just a flak on cnn
don lemon and chris hayes so they're
going to go head to head
who's going to win between don lemon and
chris hayes
don lemon said the walls are closing in
on trump but chris hayes said
a cornered president storms out as the
mueller probe closes in which was going
to go
then they're going to go head to head
they're going to go and these are
four segments distinct segments of
people and it's very telling by the way
that john brennan
is in the cable news segment because
these guys are all working together
that's i mean that's what's so
damaging about this that's what's so
corrupt
about how this whole hoax investigation
started it wasn't just the democrats
funding some oppo research
if it were the democrats funding some
oppa research whatever
republicans fundapo research that's what
it is
it's that the democrats funded oppo
research
and then the oppo research firm used a
foreign intelligence contact
who had ties to the u.s intelligence
agencies
and the usdoj had ties
to the oppo research firm not just loose
ties ties of marriage
that were never disclosed as a conflict
of interest
and then once the democrats paid for
that oppo research
using the foreign intelligence then they
tipped off
the federal government and the federal
government used that bought and paid for
oppo research to launch an investigation
to surveil the trump campaign and then
once they did that
other people within the federal
government handed it off to the media
because they're all in bed together
and then the media created a ton of
public pressure and hysteria
based on nothing
that then pressured the federal
government and the politicians
to launch an even greater investigation
that gave us
two years of lies that were then
parroted again
and again and again for by the
mainstream media
791 consecutive days for an average of
three minutes a night
spreading a lie a whole investigation
and they're still spreading lies
and they're still unapologetic that's
what's so corrupt about it
if it were just one segment you could
isolate it if it were just cnn
you'd say okay you're a bunch of clowns
tune them out if it were just
the federal government you could fire
the crooks
if it were just the electeds you know
they're electeds you vote them out of
office
but it's not it's this sick cabal
working together
that's the problem that's why we need
the investigation
john brennan is he a cable news talking
header is he
former cia director i don't know
he certainly never should have been the
cia director
now he just goes on as a flak for
democrats he said that donald trump
quote is wholly in the pocket of putin
not mincing words not just making an
insinuation or implying something
he says trump quote is holy in the
pocket of putin
now here's how he explains himself
i'm just curious uh mr director
how surprised were you uh by the
findings
uh yesterday by the conclusions that
were drawn
and uh i'm just curious did you receive
bad information throughout this process
like so many of us did
that there was more there than ended up
in the report regarding collusion
well i don't know if i received that
information but i think i suspected that
there was more than there actually was
and i i am relieved that it's been
determined that there was not a criminal
conspiracy
with the russian government um over our
election i think that is good news for
the country
and so i still point to things that were
done publicly or
efforts to try to have conversations
with the russians that were
inappropriate
but um i'm not all that surprised that
the high bar of criminal conspiracy was
not met
i am surprised at that second part of
obstruction of justice in terms of how
it came out
i don't know whether or not bob mueller
wanted the attorney general to
pronounce on that issue and whether or
not bob mueller felt it would be best
for congress american people to
determine
whether the weight of the information
indicates that
donald trump did try to obstruct justice
so
there are some surprises there and
that's why i think getting to the full
muller report
is the best way to get some of these if
not all of these questions
first of all that last part he said is
just bs that's just total bs to say
that i don't know if robert mueller
wanted
the attorney general to pronounce on the
question of obstruction of justice
he certainly did want
barr to pronounce on the question of
obstruction of justice
that's the only possible outcome that
could have happened when bob mueller did
not
come to a conclusion so bob mueller is
is analyzing
obstruction of justice and he presents
arguments for both sides he
doesn't complete his homework assignment
he turns it in the ag
has to come to a conclusion because
there's there's a potential crime here
if the ag
just said well i don't know i don't know
he wouldn't be doing his job
because let's say donald trump did
obstruct justice then they would have to
go after him
let's say members of the trump
administration did obstruct justice they
would have to indict them
the ag has a job the ag is not a cable
commentator
the ag is not a pundit the ag has a job
to do
to enforce the law so bob mueller by
leaving that open
for his boss whose job it is to come to
the conclusions
he is saying you have to come to the
conclusion because i am not going to do
it so that's just bs
and then he said well yeah you know i'm
well glad glad that uh
russia didn't take over our country
um but uh but i still still stand by
a lot of what i said you said trump is
wholly in the pocket of putin that was a
lie that was obviously
not true apologize or shut up
that's fine if you don't want to
apologize and you get everything
completely wrong
then shut up because your opinion is
worth nothing
and your judgment is worth nothing and
you have no humility at all even to
admit that
but he can't shut up so we might want to
we might want to play into that a little
bit
that's fine if he doesn't want to shut
up maybe we should bring him in for some
investigations
maybe we should find out what his role
was in all of this maybe we should find
out what john brennan knew
maybe we should find out what the
intelligence agencies knew
during the obama administration when
they launched
these illegal this illegal surveillance
of the trump campaign
maybe we should find out who was talking
to whom that sounds like a good idea
john brennan doesn't want to shut up
fine run your mouth buddy run your mouth
all the way into an orange jumpsuit
or at least tell us what we need to know
to figure out who is behind
this major political scandal
so that we can get to the bottom of this
and have some justice not water under
the bridge
not oh too bad they're going to do it
again they're still trying to do it
and there needs to be consequences to
show them that they can't get away with
these sort of things we've got a lot
more to get to we've got lindsey grambo
coming out for a new investigation we've
got a pretty dumb article
in the new york times and we've got the
green new deal but
first go to dailywire.com ten bucks a
month one hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the
android cleveland show you get the bench
up hero show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get the matt wall show
you get to ask questions backstage don't
forget to ask questions mail bag coming
up on thursday
and do you get this the most important
week for this obviously if you are
listening to this right now
or watching this you already are a
subscriber because otherwise you would
have drowned and left its tears
go to dailywire.com we'll be right back
by the way tonight at 7 00 pm pacific
time
10 pm eastern time at the university of
redlands
i will be harvesting delicious leftist
tears if there are any left to be
cried out during my latest speech on my
young americas foundation tour
come on out bring a friend bring some
questions and as always bring
your empty tumblers it is going to be a
very fun night
so the media aspect
takes care of itself these guys are a
bunch of schmucks they got it completely
wrong they have no credibility we
shouldn't listen to a word they say
all we need to do is tune them out the
people we need to investigate are the
current and
ex-government officials who were who
perpetrated this hoax
who perpetrated this crime we need to
investigate them immediately
lindsey graham beau agrees with me what
makes no sense to me
is all the abuse by the department of
justice
and the fbi the unprofessional conduct
the shady behavior
nobody seems to think that's much
important
well that's going to change i hope i've
been calling
since the end of 2017. for a special
counsel to be appointed
to look at whether or not the fisa
warrant process was abused
for political purposes whether or not a
counterintelligence investigations
was opened up regarding the trump
campaign as a backdoor to spy on the
campaign
that's what we need to know we need to
know it
i'm glad that grambo is coming out there
and calling for it that's what we need i
know we
say we're done with the investigations
it's so tedious it's i know it is i know
that's the hard work of government
that's the hard work of politics
and we've just got to do it now speaking
of the hard work of government some of
the
lighter and more fun side of this mitch
mcconnell
cocaine mitch is currently
it may have already happened calling for
a vote
for the green new deal this is what he
said
i'll try to do it in my best cocaine
mitch voice i could not be more glad
that they haven't no
no sort of like cocaine that's what i
imagine
when i see cocaine mitch is just say
hello to my little
but this is what he said he said quote i
could not be more glad that the american
people will have the opportunity to
learn precisely where each one of their
senators stands on the green new deal
a radical top-down socialist makeover
of the entire u.s economy
and then you know he had that little
cocaine smirk right there at the end
because i just love him so much so the
green new deal proposed
by alexandria ocasio-cortez
socialist from new york it would ban
planes trains and automobiles over 88
of the american energy industry
obviously because of that on day one it
would kill 5.8 million jobs
but because it's taking out the energy
industry it would take away all of the
other jobs
shortly thereafter it calls to knock
down every building in the country and
then rebuild every building in the
country within
10 years that's just the beginning i
could go on about this i'll probably be
speaking about this at the university of
redlands this evening
okay
cocaine mitch says all right alexandria
we'll bring this up for a vote when she
proposed it
there was a green new deal resolution in
the senate and
it was co-sponsored by every
democrat who is currently running for
president from the senate
liz warren cory booker kamala harris
bernie sanders all amy klobuchar
all coming out to say yes this is what
we want because they're all running to
see who's the craziest radical leftist
for 2020. it's okay they're all behind
it alexandria ocasio-cortez this is what
she's asking for
all these senators this is what they're
asking for so cocaine mitch says
okay we'll bring it up for a vote
and do you know what they say alexandria
ocasio-cortez is furious
she just this just broke i'll just read
it straight from
the breaking news articles she said
alexandria ocasio-cortez says
mitch mcconnell doesn't want to save our
planet
he's bringing up her legislation
he says cocaine mitch thinks oh it's i
don't think she called him cocaine mitch
but says mitch mcconnell thinks quote
we can all drink oil in 30 years
what no he's no no no alexandria he's
bringing up your legislation for a vote
no no it's okay no unless your
legislation is going to have us all
drinking oil in 30 years
what mitch mcconnell's doing is that
he's trying to rush this bill to the
floor without a hearing
without working through committee
because he doesn't want to save our
planet
she is so upset why is she so upset
because the green new deal is a joke and
everyone knows it's a joke
even alexandria ocasio-cortez knows it's
a joke even her handlers know it's a
joke and every single person in the
senate
co-sponsoring it knows it's a joke
you can't do it the price tag is 93
trillion dollars
you would have to cut off all government
spending
all i mean abolish the military cut off
every department of the government
except i guess for the irs
and then after collecting
taxes for 30 years maybe you could start
to pay for it except obviously the
economy would crash before then
it is not serious but aoc wrote draft
legislation for this thing
it's their bill that cocaine mitch is
bringing to the floor and what he's
doing is calling out their hypocrisy
and their childishness and they are
whining and screaming and crying like
children this is a great
bit i mean i guess cocaine mitch had
just been waiting
for the gop's greatest week ever because
you've got boom russia collusion's down
boom
trump is totally exonerated boom michael
avenatti is going to jail
boom obamacare's invalidated boom the
glaciers are growing
boom boom boom boom get every single
democrat senator on the record
for the green new deal it's beautiful
stuff it's going to come back to haunt
them in the general election in 2020
cocaine mitch
does have a view of the long game that's
clearly what he's playing here
this is a really impossible situation
in politics you always want to put your
opponent in an impossible situation
and that's exactly what he's doing here
all of these people who have
co-sponsored the green new deal legis uh
draft
resolution have to vote for it they
would be
rank hypocrites if they don't vote for
the green new deal if they vote for the
green new deal that actually might help
them in the primary though it
honestly it might not who knows how this
primary is going to shape out
but it is going to kill them in the
general election every gop ad
in 2020 is going to be about this stupid
thing and they're going to be furious at
aoc
and this might cut aoc's career short
too which is why
she's fighting so strongly against it
really really
great stuff before we get out of here i
want to one i'd like to thank the good
lord for this wonderful newsweek
that has been so greatly enjoyable and
very good for our nation
but i'd also like to call your attention
to
the new york times there was an op-ed in
the new york times by peter atterton
and the op-ed was called a god
problem perfect all-powerful
all-knowing the idea of the deity most
westerners accept
is actually not coherent
okay if i were the new york times and i
had a week like they just had i would
probably be questioning god's existence
too
but this is really important because
virtually every question i get in the
mail bag when i go to these speeches
is religious in nature either it's
religious in a tangential way or it is
directly religious
and it's because you have an entire
generation i guess now two generations
millennials and
zoomers who were raised without religion
who were raised religiously unaffiliated
or in some milk toast quasi religion
cafeteria catholic whatever
they were raised to even even at the
most religious they were raised with the
idea that there is a god without wrath
leading a people without sin
to a kingdom without judgment through
the ministrations of a christ without a
cross
as a theologian who escapes my mind
famously said
most people i think are attracted to
some sense of meaning they need meaning
we have this misery crisis in the
country
young people are more miserable than
they've ever been anxiety stress
suicidality are all skyrocketing
teenage suicide is up 70
millennials more than any other
generation
are looking for purpose in their jobs
and we kind of joke about this we say
shut up and do your job
stop trying to make everything about
social justice but
the reason they want that is they don't
feel purpose anywhere else in their
lives
they need to feel purpose somewhere they
need to feel meaning somewhere
and this crisis
is i think well it's obviously caused by
the devil ultimately
but what it's caused by in a more
proximate way
is the lack of education the lack of
culture
and the degradation of not just our
universities but even
our journalists even our our news sites
and this is a prime example of that this
is a very bad op-ed
it's not compelling it deals in a very
shallow way with big ideas
and it it makes a terrible argument
against god it reminds me of
when christopher hitchens and richard
dawkins and all those guys
had that little publishing movement in
the mid-2000s the new atheists
it was never really a serious
philosophical movement but it was a
publishing phenomenon
and they they didn't really make
arguments against god
but they wrote books christopher
hitchens wrote a book god is not great
and the the book never took on the
question of whether or not god is great
he just pointed out that religious
groups have done bad things
at some points throughout history and
this was heralded as some great
great mind some great work some real
powerful thoughts this is what we're
seeing here and and stupid things like
this
encourage people in their delusions that
life has no meaning and it really uh
exacerbates the problem so i just want
to go through very quickly some of the
stupid ideas in this short column
and uh and point out how dumb they are
because it's very fun to do that as well
with the new york times so
the column begins if you look up god in
a dictionary
first of all you know people when you
when you are writing
or when you are giving a speech or a
eulogy or a toast
the worst way that you can possibly
begin is
when i looked up such and such in the
dictionary it said blah blah blah
but to me it means so much more or to
this merriam-webster's dictionary
defines i mean this is the
cliche worst way to begin a piece of
writing or an oration
so no wonder it ends up in the new york
times that's just a little bit of advice
for you if you're ever giving a best man
toast
or a eulogy or something don't do that
okay
if you look up god in a dictionary the
first entry you will find will be
something along the lines of quote
a being believed to be infinitely
perfect wise
and powerful creator and ruler of the
universe
okay certainly if applied to non-western
contexts that would be puzzling but in a
western context this is how philosophers
have understood god
the question does the idea of a morally
perfect all-powerful all-knowing god
make sense
does it hold together when we examine it
logically
um yes yes so you could just stop
the article there but let's go on to see
what he thinks let's consider the
attribute of omnipotence
you've probably heard the paradox of the
stone before can god create a stone that
cannot be lifted
if he can create such a stone then he's
not all powerful since he cannot lift it
on the other hand
if he cannot create a stone that cannot
be lifted then he is not all-powerful
since he cannot create the unliftable
stone either way god is not all-powerful
so this is something that when freshmen
students in college smoke pot during
their first semester and sit around at
night they think this is really profound
they think this is a really powerful
motive what what is actually written
there is
more uh semantically similar to
that doesn't really mean anything now he
acknowledges that in a sense
he acknowledges that god cannot do
self-contradictory things
as thomas aquinas acknowledged but he
says
other people believe that god can do
self-contradictory things
rene descartes thinks this now what this
author doesn't write is that actually
muslims think this as well pope benedict
channeling ibn hazim the muslim scholar
talks about this how a difference
between the god of christianity and the
god of islam
is that the god of christianity is a god
of intellect and will
perfect intellect and perfect will
whereas the god of islam is in
is all will allah is so
utterly willful that if allah willed for
you to worship idols
you would have to worship idols even
though this is
self-contradictory he doesn't go there
because that's politically incorrect so
he says but renee descartes thought that
thomas aquinas was wrong
like okay yeah i don't know joe blow
down the street thinks that thomas
aquinas is wrong too but joe blows a
dummy
so okay he kind of skips that though he
kind of
uh he says okay it evidently would be a
world very different from the world that
we currently
inhabit if god could create a world in
which evil does not exist
but it's a possible world all the same
indeed if god is morally perfect
it's difficult to see why he would have
created such a why he wouldn't have
created such a world so why didn't he
okay so he's saying why is there evil in
the world
now this is the only argument
against god that really has any strength
whatsoever
and and actually it ends up being an
argument for god he points out
that according to alvin plantinga a a
favorite of mine
to create creatures capable of moral
good god must create
creatures capable of moral evil and he
can't give these creatures the freedom
to perform evil at the same time
preventing them from doing so right the
reason
that evil exists is because we have
freedom
now why would god create a world with
freedom if freedom necessitates that
evil would exist
possibly because that's the greatest
possible world this is what we sing on
easter we say
o happy fault that one for us so great
so glory as a savior the fall of man the
pride
the original sin results in the fall of
man it results in all these awful things
but then it wins for us redemption which
is the greatest possible world
okay and then this guy says but it
doesn't explain as darwin noticed
why there's so much pain and suffering
in the animal kingdom why there's so
much
physical suffering caused by non-human
causes like
earthquakes or something the way john
milton explains this
is the way the paul explains this which
is that the original sin that ruins
perfection
doesn't just result in one person's free
will
affecting only himself that's not how
freedom works that's not how our actions
in the world work
what happens is that when sin enters the
world sin pervades the world
and death comes from sin evil all of
this is pervading the world your actions
are not limited to yourself we know this
if i swing my hand i could knock over my
leftist ears tumbler i'd spill the
leftist tears
all over the ground that would seep in
that would create mold someone might
walk into the room and breathe in the
mold
these endless number of
effects of my evil of when i commit a
sin
this is actually what the doctrine of
indulgences is about we don't have time
to go into that here but this is a
question that many deeper thinkers than
this guy in the new york times
have thought about for a long time
he goes on he says what about god's
infinite knowledge if god knows all
there is to know then he knows at least
as much as we know but if he knows that
what we know
then this would detract from his
perfection because there are some things
that we know that if they are also known
to god
would make him a sinner which of course
is in contradiction to the concept of
god
one cannot know lust and envy unless one
has experienced them
now this is not true i know
i can know cancer without having
experienced cancer
a doctor knows quite a lot about cancer
when he's operating on a cancer patient
it doesn't mean he has to have had
cancer himself one does not need to have
experience of these things to have
knowledge of these things
he goes on he talks about uh well he
tries to he
rings this one for a little while that
it doesn't do very well
and he refers to logical inconsistencies
he says these it's logical
inconsistencies like these that led the
17th
century french theologian blaise pascal
not really a theologian by the way he
was a mathematician
to reject reason as a basis for faith
and return to the bible and revelation
it is said that when pascal died his
servant found sown into the
his jacket the words god of abraham god
of isaac god of jacob
not of the philosophers and scholars
okay and
he's saying because pascal rejected
reason as the basis for faith that's
wrong blaise pascal of course was a
member of
a largely heretical christian movement
called janzenism
it was uh which was uh roundly condemned
many times for for getting things wrong
blaise pascal one of the great geniuses
but can get certain things wrong
i go through this one because it's fun
to knock down stupid arguments even if
we have very limited time and we can't
go into it in as much
much depth as we would like to but i
bring this up because this is the point
on the media that we've been making all
week
now in its most fundamental way
it's the point that i repeat again and
again it's the point that dr johnson
made
all shallows are clear shallow
thinking is clear shallow news reporting
is clear
shallow conspiracies are clear
conspiracies are so clear it was so
clear
that donald trump was a puppet of
vladimir putin to quote
john brennan it was so clear that donald
trump colluded with the russians it's so
clear that god couldn't exist
it's so clear it's in the new york times
shallows are clear
and we need to crack ourselves out of
shallow thinking we need to stop being
so
damn gullible and falling for it i hope
people get that lesson
but they don't and it's not just on
little political scandals
big political scandals which in the
grand scheme of things are little it's
on big questions fundamental questions
too
we'll see let's hope our eyes are opened
we've got a lot more
come back tomorrow maybe i'll see you at
the university of redlands tonight
in the meantime i'm michael knowles this
is the michael noel show see you then
the michael knowles show is produced by
robert sterling executive producer
jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan haye our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by danny d'amico
audio is mixed by dylan case hair and
makeup is by jessua overa
production assistant nick sheehan the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2019.
today on the ben shapiro show president
trump has the best
day of his presidency maybe in history
that's today on the ben shapiro show